you welcome to this video just kit okay
it's the opponent's name mm okay can
just play very classic got set up here
c6 mmm yeah ticking all the check here
but she's okay i'm going to drag with
the chickens a very solid continuation I
don't think you will take actually but
it's a decent pre-move why not okay yeah
normal asst exactly yeah something like
that no black IAM is arguing that he's
got a decent solid structure okay no he
takes okie dokie yeah what about this
yeah I guess maybe rook e8 covering this
well what black is arguing him is that
he's got a very very decent structure
with them gather white Bishop looking at
this c6 pawn it doesn't look very great
for white but it's quite clearly super
solid um yeah night c5 is going to play
before I guess jab 94 is actually quite
playable not entirely sure I don't want
to allow before just like that with the
night or a six so let's go go for that
jump let's can pre move that the only
thing that keeps me from doing those
premiums more said you just took so
awful that's difficult to make out what
my move really was okay so I'd like to
play I'd like to put the poll on f6 and
remove the night somewhere but it's
difficult difficult to see how this is
possible hmm 93 years leading nowhere I
guess
it's a very equal ish position i can i
can actually go to g5 so i don't really
think that my night is in trouble down
my ideas to go bishop is six next
yeah it's equal nothing much going on
this should be six however he might have
night xe5 okay is covering this we
should be 695 yep that is possible so
something like age six this amazing
probably not okay but it's not
threatening anything so i can go away
five on b5 i have 95 and i might open up
this yeah okay well here i can do now g5
without any particular problem it takes
before no and that's far too fancy and I
don't get the pawn somewhere to
somewhere important okie dokie night c5
might happen huh so let's go here for an
ID form and if possible no he has
prevented that okay maybe f4 would have
been a move maybe
yeah that's not really very exciting but
I don't think I'm in trouble least I
don't see exactly how he does something
here is more activity here yeah okay he
wants to take 95 yeah that is definitely
an idea I came if i go here take stinks
95 push it back should be okay one thing
my position really and in one one aspect
my position is totally ok this is the
king I'm not really behind in that
regard my king is ok so here and I mean
ok and 10 in sense of it this take part
in the game ok this takes takes Knight
c5 actually awkward because night a
sixth of the threat hmm
I know I can actually take on take on
sand for so that it's not really really
threatened bishop e6 bill should be 695
Bishop takes e4 is okay and I'm
threatening King b6 now kicking the rook
out okay threat is a strong word but
let's say it's my attention okay now I
can move this to to trade maybe I had
something more active but not sure about
it
yeah it's nothing brilliant Oh No takes
Knight takes rook e1 I overlooked that
one rupee one ok it doesn't do it uh huh
interesting time where he'd love to
trade that rope maybe this is ok he
actually night 26 would be good I'm can
I get down let's see eyes out for that
check I'm good night a 4 I can go ok aid
and I have to have to kick him back he
just does he just want to draw here and
I guess he just once it had no no I can
do this right these things
putting him in some kind of pin King be
too maybe hmm King be too as a Muslim
don't have much time here check the
position is ok I just don't have much
time as I said stood says do you phone I
could have taken a stupid check check
yeah I know just two moves to liquidate
the damn bloody last porn ah just a bit
too big to slow down yeah that was I was
always behind on time I had to defend
this slightly worse position it started
out with nothing special like here this
is just equal this position yeah it just
took a bit bit too long there because he
always had had some ideas when we never
really went for anything and just
shuffled but um
yeah i mean okay that's nothing he could
have played c-5m 70-80 process to take
c5 it's just a blunder chances a simple
move I cannot take check you have to be
five I think I'm some ok again yeah I
could have taken be five actually yeah
but I was glad that I'm I was some yeah
out of out of danger let's say 94 e I
had 16 second this is really the problem
I actually got really far and it's six
seconds here and I really managed to
make it the problem was all those pretty
primo ya okay it's just it's just i er I
really managed quite a bit there with
one second but you have to get rid of
all the plans that's difficult now just
two more moves ah what a shame ok thanks
for watching